[Music]
after DMC like we from the outside it
might have looked like we were all
suffering but we weren't we really
enjoyed working with Capcom we really
enjoyed working on that game and despite
all the flack that came most of it came
my way which is fine what was good is
just the sheer professionalism of
everyone just they want to make they
want to do the best job they can and we
know that if we can go through that and
come out you know fighting with a good
game there's nothing that can stop us
it's a it's a position of strength
from its humble beginnings developing
kung fu chaos for Xbox to reboot in one
of the most beloved Japanese franchises
of all time
Cambridge based developer Ninja Theory
has faced its fair share of challenges
although it's a relatively small
independent studio ninja theory is known
for creating large lavish action games
that tell engaging stories feature
unique worlds and have satisfying combat
these pillars are the foundation of all
its games from heavenly sword to enslave
to DMC Devil May Cry these are the games
that ninja theories developers make
because these are the games they love
and it's what the people at the heart of
the studio want to continue making but
in the current landscape of video game
development creating a ninja theory
experience is becoming increasingly
difficult and something that other
Studios are also facing so the challenge
for Ninja Theory becomes finding a place
where it can flex his creativity without
making compromises Cal played sin or
sacrifice was born from this ambition
it's an independently developed and
self-published game and with it the
studio is hoping to show other indie
developers that there's another way to
make ambitious games with high
production values ahead of the release
of hell-blade we traveled to Cambridge
England to speak to Timmy man Tony
artist co-founder of ninja theory and
creative director on hell-blade across
the next 15 minutes we're gonna explore
how the studio is forging a new path for
itself how he'll blade bridges the gap
between the indie and the triple-a game
and how the games industry as a whole
stands to benefit if others do the same
[Music]
ninja theories main goal with hell-blade
is to revive the mid-tier game which
were developed on a budget much smaller
than Triple A games but aspire to
deliver experiences that could attract
similar sized audiences yeah we do want
to we do want to bring back that mid
tier game
I mean games used to be like that I mean
all games used to be sort of that just
think of Jet Set Radio parappa the
rapper like Metal Gear Solid they all
used to live alongside each other like
ICO and not anymore they don't now now
you do have the big Triple A games and
you've got in these studios and there's
there's nothing wrong with either that
they're both you know one's a
blockbuster was very smaller creative
ideas driven I love you know I like
graphics
I like sound I like good production in
in in games and I do miss the idea of
games that look great feel great play
great but that takes some chances and
that aren't twenty hours long or you
know about sixty sixty dollars the idea
of games that exists between Indy and
Triple A is nothing new in fact many of
the most memorable games from the
PlayStation 2 Xbox and even Xbox 360 and
ps3 generation are these so called
Double A games games like I call amnesia
or Darksiders among many others along
in years about a century they were
titles that broke new ground either
through design or storytelling but also
had the trimmings that allowed them to
exist and in some cases compete with
blockbusters however in recent years but
the prevalence of blockbuster shooters
an open world experiences the scale of
development escalated dramatically to me
the tastes and demands of players the
disparity between double-a and triple-a
has become a gulf and in turn the health
of independent studios has suffered as
these mid tier games faded away the
developers shifted focus to smaller
indie productions mobile titles or
blockbusters commissioned and funded by
big publishers for ninja theory however
the idea of bringing back that Double A
game space could be a sale for Studios
of its size with similar ambitions
digital publishing has given developers
more control over their games which for
hell-blade has empowered ninja theory to
create a focused eight-hour
single-player adventure digital
platforms like Steam PSN and Xbox Live
meanwhile allow smaller studios to
circumvent many of the costs associated
with publishing box products which means
hell-blade can be priced modestly and
ninja theory thinks that these two
factors are key to revitalizing the
double-a game development space the sort
of disruption I'm talking about is not
replacing what's there
it's about finding another way for
people to create games they want to make
and to find a niche audience right but
so keeping the cost down selling it at a
good price finding its audience as
opposed to catching every audience is
something that I think is healthy and it
doesn't replace Triple A games or indie
games there's a lot of developers going
on there because they don't believe that
they can survive in triple-a and they're
not set up to be indie developers and it
seems like the only reason people aren't
finding this middle ground is because
well one for one digital was maybe a bit
too small on consoles for a while and
it's grown so that's made it possible
for many developers however there may be
the fear that without bigger budgets and
the kind of development support that
comes with blockbuster projects they may
be inhibiting their own ability to
realize their vision after all a smaller
scale naturally means more constraints
ninja theory however
firmly believes this isn't the case I
didn't feel creative it like it was a
step back I felt like he wasn't step
forward because now we had control over
what we're creating which you don't have
fully when you're working with a
publisher it's always a creative
partnership with a publisher and the
bigger the game becomes the less you can
focus on the game you know around the
principles that you think are important
so the bigger a game gets the more you
get you lose creative control over it
for me this is this is a big step
forward for us we're making our own IP
which we own we're making our own
creative decisions we're publishing it
ourselves and we want to disrupt a model
that's out there that I think doesn't
actually serve developers like us all
games players very well while there's
certainly opportunity for big publisher
funded triple-a games to depict complex
subject matter the reality is it's a
rarity the smaller budget in these
spaces where the most interesting
narratives themes and characterizations
are tackled but these are also the games
that aren't given the kind of exposure
they need to catch the attention of a
larger audience mid tier games however
are naturally more alluring as they
often speak a design language that the
broader audience understands while
grappling with complicated issues in the
triple-a space this marriage of uncommon
themes with a familiar gameplay
framework is what gave rise to Bioshock
a first-person shooter that in large
part is about objectivism and Mass
Effect a character-driven
RPG that deals with complicated social
religious and political issues in the
mid here we have something like spec ops
the line which explored the horrors of
war and player agency within it the
benefit of Double A games may not be
obvious to everyone but hell-blade is a
good example of how the types of
experiences players have could diversify
if talented dev teams are given the kind
of creative freedom an independent
studio has but Ninja Theory also
believes that there are business
advantages that will trickle down to the
consumer most notably in the ability to
cutout retail and pass those savings on
to the players
the upshot people might be wondering
well what's this ok great well done very
smart clever whatever but what's that
got to do with us like how does that
benefit us the way you benefits I think
the industry and people games players is
we've released this game for 25
thirty dollars we've cut all the costs
all the middlemen and we're offering a
different model there's a direct benefit
now which is smaller games cheaper but
that doesn't mean less quality my hope
is and quite a few people that
conferences have come to us and said
that they're watching us because they
wanted to know whether this works or not
because if it does it'll be something
they potentially would do as well
because I think there's a lot of studios
out there where they would dearly love
to take more chances and make
interesting games for their audience
instead of making their games for the
publishers so if we if we can make a
success of this we then probably share
the success or failure you know because
it works either way with with other
developers to see and give them a chance
as well you know they have every shot of
making it work yes we do why don't you
join us maybe you two have a part to
play in this story however many would
argue that the current indie blockbuster
dichotomy is supported by market demands
and despite ninja Terry's intentions and
the thought behind them there's a very
real chance that the mid-tier Double A
game space may not reimagine the way
that a wants so where does that leave
the studio so now next game I don't know
what I'll be doing but I can't go back
like I can't not take more risks like I
can't do something that's not going to
be challenging I can't let go of the
creative control to work on a massive
triple-a project I like the camaraderie
that comes with being a smaller team I
like how much you have to rely on each
other because it's not all about me like
just everything that goes on in
hell-blade is absolutely the team the
people the individuals working together
my function is direction but I don't
make the arts and the sound other you
know we've got brilliant people that do
I like that it's forced us to find
solutions like we you know we wanted to
do performance capture it would be too
expensive so we built our own we're
constantly problem solving whereas in a
large team you're constantly just
drilling down and doing the work you
know you're just doing what's told
because money solves every problem I
think we've achieved more
than we imagined we could and it's been
like that with sound with just a
graphics was just a game experience
around mental health themes and
psychosis it's really amazing how much
has been achieved looking back with such
limited resources again I'm not picking
up myself I'm picking up the spirit of a
team of really good people working
together alright thanks for watching
that was a bit inside of baseball but
I'm a huge fan of ninja theory in their
game so I'm excited to see what happens
with hell-blade and their goals for the
mid-tier game if you want to check out
more of hell-blade we've got a review of
it on games welcome and of course
there's also a video review on the
GameSpot YouTube page Mike in the US is
also doing another feature he's doing a
reboot on the mental health angle of
hell blades so subscribe the game sports
that you don't miss that in the meantime
if you've got any opinions on this
feature he'll play door Ninja Theory you
can let me know in the comments I'm
floating about there or you can find me
on twitter at two more h probably or
abuse at me on the internet I'll see you
around